[Musique]
et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
patricia tourancheau bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste de faits divers
on vous à lui longtemps dans libération
aujourd'hui dans les jours et vous
signez le grêlé le tueur était un flic
qui est sorti à quelques semaines au
seuil et qu'on va voir voilà qu'on voit
à l'antenne se livrer votre enquête
votre contre-enquête sur l'une des
affaires criminelles les plus célèbres
de l'histoire criminelle récente ici en
france 7 bits dugré les un homme que les
enquêteurs auront cherché pendant 35 ans
est-ce qu'on peut peut-être d'abord
résumé ce parcours criminel hors du
commun disons que c'est un tueur en
série qui commence par tient une petite
fille en 1986 à paris et qui
disparaît disons qu'ils changent de mode
opératoire et toute l'année 87 eelv a
agressé des jeunes filles en violet
massacré aussi des gens il se présente
avec une carte de police un talkie
walkie des menottes il a le jargon des
policiers et ces enquêtes ne vont pas
être relié par la suite les policiers
retrouvent sa trace en 1994 où il enlève
une petite fille il la viole et ensuite
le type disparaît et son adn et et
trouver à partir de 96 sur sur les
vêtements des petites filles de 86 et et
là la brigade criminelle de paris
s'aperçoit qu'ils ont affaire à un tueur
en série parce qu'il a commis plein
d'actes qui n'était pas relié les uns
avec les autres parce que le mode
opérateurs étaient complètement
différent par exemple ya un massacre
dans dans le marais à paris le 29 avril
87 un couple louis une jeune fille au
pair allemande arte on les sent et son
patron de 38 ans et ils sont torturés
ils sont ils sont massacrés elle allait
crucifier lui les garroté à l'espagnol
avec cette espèce de lit 1 enserrée par
un tisonnier derrière brûlée avec une
cigarette ça n'a rien à voir et en fait
les moyens du bord de la police
scientifique
à l'époque étant nulle
jusqu'en 96 le lien n'est pas n'est pas
fait entre tous et tous ces cas et donc
c'est pour ça que ça a pris énormément
de temps parce qu'après quand et à l'adn
du grès les qui est appelée ainsi parce
que le le premier témoin le frère de la
petite cécile bloc en fait est la
première victime qui est la première
victime en mai 86 a croisé le tueur
avant qu'ils massacrent sa petite soeur
dans l'ascenseur et lui a vu une peau
vraiment vérolé vraiment marc marquez et
les voisins ont corroboré un portrait
robot qui a été diffusé
donc il est appelé le grêlé puis on
s'aperçoit que c'est un peu une fausse
piste il a fallu mettre les enquêteurs
sur des fausses pistes alors ces
parcours criminel vous l'avez du ca 10 à
düren une dizaine une quinzaine d'années
et puis après plus rien on me dit paraît
même si effectivement les enquêteurs ont
l'adn oui jusqu'au mois de septembre
dernier un homme qui s'appelle françois
vérove ce suicide et dans sa lettre il
avoue être ce grand criminel il ne dit
pas le grêlé mais vu qu'il était
convoqué quelques jours auparavant par
un coup de fil de la police judiciaire
de montpellier en tant que anciens
gardes républicains à paris dans les
années 80 c'est ce que les enquêteurs et
la juge turc est chercher et lui parmi
tant d'autres est convoqué françois vrod
et là en fait il fait mine de rien
auprès de sa famille aucun changement
d'attitude et il disparaît de chez lui
et il avale des médicaments il laisse
une lettre posthume à sa femme dans
laquelle il explique que pendant très
longtemps donc il a eu besoin de
détruire de tuer des innocents qui l'est
ce grand criminel qui après une
dépression qui l'a fait au milieu des
années 90 il explique qu'il s'est arrêté
grâce à la thérapie que ça a été une
délivrance dit il donc on n'est pas
obligé de le croire mais peut-être que
c'est vrai et lui explique qu'il s'est
arrêté en 97 or les enquêteurs la
brigade criminelle pour eux ils
s'arrêtaient en 94 donc déjà ils
recherchent maintenant des cas des
crimes des délits qui ont été commis par
françois vérove entre 94 et 97 et donc
non seulement le tueur était
effectivement un flic au moment qu'il a
pris sa retraite quelques années plus
tard donc un flic qui a commis des actes
et des viols d'une barbarie sans nom et
puis au moment au moment où il est
acculé et c'est un papy gâteau tout ce
qu'il ya de plus ordinaire mais c'est
incroyable ce il a 59 ans quand il se
tue c'est le bon voisin le bon mari le
bon papy qui trimballe ses trois petits
enfants dans une carriole derrière son
vélo électrique un époux formidable ça
sa femme le décrit comme quelqu'un
vraiment petits soins attentionnés qui
fait la cuisine
iran servait il est conseiller municipal
à prades le lez le maire en revient
toujours pas tout le monde a été abusé
par ce type c'est vraiment il est d'une
duplicité
incroyable ce qui est singulier dans
cette affaire c'est bien sûr le profil
du tueur et aussi le fait qu'elle est
dure et donc 35 ans et qu'elle a été
marquée vous lisez tout à l'heure par
des ratés en cascade oui parce que à
partir du moment où les policiers n'ont
pas relier les dossiers en en fait la
brigade criminelle s'occuper des
premiers cas de petite fille massacrées
tuées violées en 86 la brigade de
protection des mineurs s'occuper de tous
les cas de viol d'adolescente et et
d'agressions et de jeunes filles accosté
par le faux policier croyait-il en 87
après en 94 ingrid elle est enlevée en
seine-et-marne et les violets dans les
gendarmes après l'adn permet de relier
tous ces cas y compris au massacre du
marais des deux adultes dont s'occupait
un autre groupe de la brigade criminelle
donc déjà il ya énormément de retard
l'adn en france on a dix ans de retard
par rapport aux anglais et par rapport
d'ailleurs le frère de cécile bloc le
grand frère qui était biologiste et déjà
à l'époque avait avant si la police
judiciaire de paris que il existait un
truc en angleterre incroyable qui
s'appelait l'adn qui permettait
d'incriminer formellement les coupables
mais la france avait trop de retard à
qui à quoi doit-on que l' enquête n'ait
jamais été refermée
je pense
à l'adn et aux enquêteurs c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment les dossiers ont
été refermés vers 92 93 par la justice
et ensuite
l'avènement la révolution de l'adn fait
que tous les dossiers anciens sur tous
les crimes contre des petites filles
sont ressortis et sur un bout de
moquette qui recouvrait le corps de la
petite cécile bloc en fait y avait du
sperme qui a permis d'identifier un adn
et à partir de là tous les dossiers sont
rouverts est relié par par l'adn fait
affaire donc a été pendant trente cinq
ans une affaire non élucidée donc une
enquête qui piétine la france a
longtemps été en retard sur la façon
qu'on avait d'abord des ces affaires non
élucidées au col crise en mauvais
français en mars dernier un nouveau pôle
judiciaire dédié précisément à ces
crimes en série c'est à faire donner
l'idée a été lancée à l'instar de ce qui
se fait en matière de terrorisme ou de
délinquance financière la tâche est
immense pour la tâche est immense mais
c'est passionnant et c'est essentiel une
telle unité judiciaire pour rassembler
justement tous ces cas anciens non
élucidés en france c'est primordial
parce que sinon les juges d'instruction
ils ont chacun 120 130 dossiers à
instruire dans leur cabinet ils peuvent
pas passer tout leur temps sur sur une
affaire ancienne alors que là avec un
pôle dédié ça permet de vraiment d'avoir
plus de temps d'avoir aussi a les
compétences ceux ci qui sont là ce que
enquêter sur des crimes anciens c'est
quand même pas c'est pas évident en quoi
un juge
normal il a sans arrêt des affaires qui
arrivent et qui sont chaudes et donc il
faut il faut y aller parce que le temps
est un an et demi le temps est un ennemi
d'un et là ce qui complique encore la
tâche dans l'histoire du grès les c'est
que le mec effectivement disparaît à
partir de 94 97 donc son adn était bien
dans le fichier national des empreintes
génétiques qui engrange en fait tous les
adn des des délinquants des suspects des
gens qui passent en garde à vue et donc
les enquêteurs ont longtemps espéré que
derrière la faveur d'une bagarre de
n'importe quoi le type se fasse prélever
l'adn qui soit dans le fichier puis que
ça match ça met en regard avec les
traces en fait génétiques inconnues qui
était sur cécile blog sur ingrid sur
toutes les autres et ça jamais sanaa
match et du coup les policiers le
croyait mort ou parti à l'étranger
de qu'elles n'ont pas lâché c'est ça qui
est à cette dingue oui alors au même
titre que l' affaire grégory chevaline
xavier dupont de ligonnès elles font
partie ces histoires de la mémoire
collective ya une forme de constance
dans notre rapport à ces affaires là à
ces énigmes judiciaires vous y voyez
l'expression de quad une forme de
fascination morbide de voyeurisme de la
ligue par rapport au public chez
certaines personnes sont fascinées de
façon malsaine pas mal d'autres sont
intéressés je veux dire les énigmes ça
passionne les gens et c'est normal tout
le monde a envie de savoir qui
réellement attaché le petit grégory et
puis la jetée dans la vologne tout le
monde a envie de savoir ce qu'est devenu
dupont de ligonnès est ce qu'il est
vivant s qui s'est tuée c'est c'est
humain je veux dire et vous et moi ce
qui me passionne c'est ce qui me
passionne c'est à la fois l' enquête à
le
la chasse aux indices pour recoller tous
les morceaux et est arrivé à comprendre
une histoire et puis c'est aussi le la
personnalité des criminels je veux dire
un grêlé c'est pas c'est pas rien
françois berreur 20 si le type a
réellement réussi à s'arrêter après une
thérapie
c'est ça c'est du jamais vu en france en
tout cas enfin ou ou peut-être que des
tueurs en série se sont arrêtés on est
qu'on ne sait pas mais en tout cas c'est
assez dingue de rentrer dans la vie et
dans dans le lit chez plusieurs
chapitres un qui s'appelle françois en
famille qui est vu à travers les yeux de
sa femme qui n'a rien ce qui s'est
aperçu de rien même pas qu'il fumait
alors que le grêlé sur ces crimes les
séries matinales fume donc c'est
incroyable et puis et puis je faire
notre chapitre c'est vérove sous
l'uniforme ou là comment il et quand il
les gardes républicains à cheval
dans les protocoles les parades de
l'état et et après comment il devient
policy motocyclisme et ça ça ça me
passionne et c'est un livre passionnant
le grêlé le tueur était un flic une
résolution de la sphère baer qui donne
peut-être de l'espoir aux enquêteurs et
surtout aux familles des victimes parce
qu'on a parlé des cap médiatique connu
il y en a des milliers d'autres dont on
parle moins hakim qui sont un peu
oubliés sur des étagères merci beaucoup
merci de faire votre choix d'être venu
nous présenter ce livre donc le tueur
était un flic un livre passionnant
sortie autsai très bonne journée mais
rien bientôt de se retrouver après la
pause avec dany coquet